the only way you hate on it this hard is
because you don't do [__] in your own
life what it does it reflects in them
their own inadequacies in life because
they want to frame themselves as the
people who help the downtrod it not
realizing they never take individual
steps themselves they only complain
about the system so they see someone
doing a real tangible change and rather
than celebrating it even though it's
affecting them like thousands of lives
of people who are struggling they want
to be like no because it would mean that
they would have to take accountability
in their own lives and to do action but
they don't want to starting with this
controversy and massive growing backlash
against YouTuber and entrepreneur Mr
Beast following him putting out a video
where he donated 20 000 pairs of shoes
to kids in South Africa well Jimmy at
one point in the video even saying these
were their first ever pair of shoes and
while many people's reaction to this was
wow stuff like this it restores my faith
and Humanity we're seeing good being
done in the world you also had a big
growing group of people questioning the
philanthropy behind all this saying
things like this isn't really Charities
and he's using needy people as props to
make himself look like the good guy
weed's going viral saying let me know
when you all catch up and realize how
weird this [__] is but in
general those criticizing Mr Beast and
the content right they were talking
about the the nature and incentives of
Charity content right with a number of
those people arguing there are plenty of
wealthy people who do Public Access
service but quote don't frame that work
as weird voyeuristic stunts and others
adding so weird that 20 000 children
need to rely on a rich white man from
the West to have their basic needs met
and get their faces plastered on the
internet so he can earn clout but do
that you had others who support the
content saying no he's making this
content not only to inspire others to do
the same aim but also by making that
content he's able to foot the bill Mr
Beast even responding to one of his
critics saying no hey you probably just
haven't seen this channel but actually
it is a charity and I obviously don't
profit from it 100 of all revenue from
Beast philanthropy goes towards running
my food banks and helping ease human
suffering and since Inception I've
personally put in millions into Beast
philanthropy that's the whole point make
content around helping people to
generate more money to help more people
like this is so similar to the last
thing somebody said that imagine a rich
white man having to go there and why are
the South Africans providing for these
young people
why aren't our governments providing
people the ability to see again with a
cheap eye surgery
there's gaps in the world there's holes
in places
and there are people like Mr Beast who
are willing to go and help those people
and I think it's so fascinating that
it's never the people that are helped
that are complaining it's everyone else
it's the people who generally have no
history or no tracker of volunteerism or
any kind of philanthropy themselves they
want to sit there from their little
Twitter accounts and say all kinds of
crazy stuff
but I ask what kind of Engagement have
you have you been involved in even on a
small level that's accessible to you and
generally the answer is very little and
I think this is probably one of the
things I hate the most uh about leftists
so in particular is that
they always cry about systemic change
and systemic this not realizing that
they have agency in their own lives to
affect change on a community and local
level
and what they do is instead of actually
making any effort to make tangible
changes they just sit there and twiddle
their thumbs on Twitter you know say
what you want about right-wing people
but I actually see religious folks
taking missionary trips to go help
people even if I don't agree with those
all the time at least they put in Boots
on the ground or paging their time out
of their their year to go and try to
help people in a tangible way they run
the stuff in their local communities to
help people in a change of way it's very
rarely the left-leading people all they
want to do is protest and cry about
systemic issues
you know and you can sit there and be
like why is the white man why don't you
ask yourself why isn't the black
government providing that to those kids
over there in South Africa because let
me tell you a lot of issues with South
African government exist today
and it ain't white people around that
country
so I just think it's interesting that
the people who are helped are never the
ones complaining it's always the people
on the outside who don't even do
one-third of the work go ahead I'm not
gonna go and be like oh it's time like
especially in South Africa this black
people running this country because
South Africa has a uh a history of
systemic whatever and white people
sending them back whatever I'm not going
to go into that but anyways I'm not
going to be whatever but you can't you
can't bring it up you can't bring it up
and say I'm not good you brought it up
so you did you can't say I'm not gonna
mention this Counterpoint and then not
go into it no I said I'm no I'm not I'm
not I'm not and I choose not to okay
well then I will counter that by saying
you can say that but their government is
entirely black and even though there is
a history of apartheid that has affected
the country there is no doubt that there
is a tremendous amount of corruption by
black individuals so you can't be
mentioning the white part see exactly no
because because here's why I did that
because you said it and just try to walk
away from it because it was the reason
why I didn't say I didn't go into that
for that except you didn't go into that
to that what you just did right now was
explain why
when when you first mentioned it you
just mentioned it like that it's like
that is it's not all that there's more
information to add to that so that's why
I'm not going to go into that because
you didn't say everything now you did
yes okay you taking conservation that
yes there is systemic uh issues that
happen with the government in the past I
put them in this place and now you now
you put a context around that so now we
can go into that but you just did you
know what I mean but I was not about to
touch that because you you didn't
explain it fully and now me saying that
triggered you into cleaning expanding
everything in the context into that into
that because just saying that oh well
you know what
it's black people running the country
and he should do something about it and
then running off of that doesn't explain
the whole context about that if you put
in the the the the the if you put in it
um
was a word
if you put in the corruption and if you
put in all the issues that there is and
how it's set up then it makes more sense
that's why I didn't want to go there
because it was not all said but that's
not it's not even part of the
conversation also it's not the whole
thing about the conversation no but
people are trying to frame it as a white
man from the West coming in to [__] [__]
up and the reason why I said that I was
like it's not white folks who are
[__] this [__] up right now for black
folks in a lot of Africa that's a lot of
our own people and that's something that
we have to be accountable for so this
narrative that whiteness is the majority
of the issue don't get me wrong there's
places where Western intervention has
[__] up certain countries and that's
absolutely true but how you gonna blame
a white individual high blood out the
locals when the Black governments who
have the power to do so choose their own
family lineage and their own wealth as a
means to perpetuate their wealth rather
than helping the people so that's what I
was just going against I just thought
the comment was deflective but we can
agree to disagreement no we agree I'm
not none of those things wherever you I
always I've always said that whenever
you give and then you don't give your
consent to people don't get their they
don't give their content and then you
fill them in the give and I don't think
that this is the case right
um he's helping people
and he's not making money out of that
yeah but you know uh but it's a white
man why is it a white man
my issue with that is I feel like they
can we can never win because the same
people that are saying on Twitter well
why is a woman go are the same people
that are turning around and looking at
Elon Musk and looking at uh basil and
say like why don't you help all those
countries and then you got one guy that
actually helps those countries and you
still got something to say so if Elon
and basil it makes me think that if Elon
and basil will turn around and help
those countries you would be like white
people helping those countries like I
feel like that's what will happen you
actually you actually have a guy that
has the power to do something
and he has the money and he actually
does it what you've been saying and with
people and with with the the left has
been complaining about for a couple of
past years and now you finally have one
dude that does it but not only has he
does it like giving away money but he's
he does it in a way that he can actually
make money to help other people like he
makes this thing not viable and you're
still not happy so I feel like this is
never the issue is not all those rich
people making money and not helping the
poor
I don't think the issue which what your
issue is with that I don't think your
issue is that white man helping no you
want issues you want issues to complain
about
I would say this I think it goes a step
further I think when people see folks
engaging this kind of philanthropy and
not doing things on a systemic level
what it does it reflects on them their
own inadequacies in life because they
want to frame themselves as the people
who help the downtrod it not realizing
they never take individual steps
themselves they only complain about the
system so they see someone doing a real
tangible change and rather than
celebrating it even though it's
affecting them like thousands of lives
of people who are struggling they want
to be like no because it would mean that
they would have to take accountability
in their own lives and to do action but
they don't want to that's what it is
that's what it is the only way you hate
on it this hard is because you don't do
[__] in your own life because anybody
who actually helps other people
in their communities would never talk
like this if you volunteered at a soup
kitchen if you've done Community work
you understand how much it changes the
lives of the individuals there so for
you to sit there and complain about it I
know you ain't done [__] in life and the
thing about it is that you're gonna be
like
yeah but why don't you have the system
why don't you show up the system knowing
them all it takes more than that and he
could you could only do so one dude can
only do so much and when you start to
want to help the whole system when
you're one guy or one organization
that's where you lose money true that's
where you lose money all those companies
all those companies that that are taking
people's money right and saying that
they're gonna name them name them UNICEF
ux fam they go out there they use your
money because they want to help a system
or whatever at a bigger scale right what
happens most of that money that you give
like 70 to 80 of what you give goes out
into Administration true so true having
worked at those Charities I can tell you
that's absolutely true 70 to 80 percent
more
um it's not just Red Cross and stuff
like that
what's the one here in Canada that's
really important Red Cross no the one
that does all kinds of Charities it's
like a big one it does like uh
fundraising for a bunch of different
little cherries but it's a big one that
takes care of us you remember then no
okay so sorry keep going but but but the
thing is that when you try to work at it
if you know a little bit about that and
you work in those if you're worse in
those in this industry because at the
end of the day it is you know how it
works you know that a lot a lot of it is
all the money is really a lot of the
money is wasted a lot of money isn't
wasted go ahead I'll also say this
anybody who says he's doing this for
cloud i'm like [__] you ain't seen
missed videos the ones have nothing to
do with philanthropy are some of the
biggest videos in the world the idea
that he needs this to further his own
reputation and his own clap he's already
the biggest YouTuber in the world how
does the philanthropy stuff is a
necessity is beyond he doesn't need to
do this this is something he's choosing
to do yeah and he waited until he was
famous famous to do it and some people
are actually on the point at you if you
played a video again it would like a lot
of people are go ahead relax you know
what are you saying because what he was
about to say is that a lot of people are
going to in his past videos and saying
like look how he's doing that now with
that you still had people questioning Mr
Beast intent which is really a hard
argument to have because he can never
really see inside of someone's heart
inside of someone's soul and there you
actually had critics going back to some
of Mr B's early charity content with him
finding and posting Clips like this most
people get mad and say this is a bad way
to get views tell them like you're okay
with this are you okay with it hell yeah
that's right yeah my life right here
homeless people don't care if I use them
for views they're thinking that video
and they're saying that's the that's the
thing that he does in the back that's
the thing that's the stuff that he did
in the back and in the in the past and
then he's he's the same way now
you guys really do not believe in
evolution
you cannot understand or believe that
someone can evolve like what I did 10
years like I'm gonna bring I know like
my mind is really everywhere when I
speak about those stuff because there's
so much stuff that comes in you're the
same people that can't forgive uh Chris
Brown
what he did back then is the same dude
until he dies and you can't forgive him
but but but the same people say no I
believe in Rehabilitation and we
shouldn't kill people
this should happen and you really don't
think that people should evolve same
thing with Chris Brown
when did [__] happened he was 19.
now he's 30. you still cannot get a
break I mean you're not fair to refer to
them Chris is engaging some weird
Behavior over the years I can understand
you know it's hard to say he's involved
I can understand that and I agree I'm
not a lover hater of him but it's not
like this dude I mean yeah but every
time in the past couple of years the
only time I was hearing about his Chris
Brown is people referencing the thing
that he did when he was 19. as bad as
what Chris Brown did Rihanna's a
billionaire
but but she can be let's say that's part
of her journey that's what she needs to
go through to me
but you're the people you're the people
that the same people that want people to
forgive and forget no you need to forget
because it's not good to hold grudges
and then you you are doing that you're
holding grudges it's like 50. if 50
never got shot would he be as big as
he is Manny Man many many men like if
you've never had that what have you been
as rich as he is today I don't know and
if you ask him would you give up them
shots for the I don't think he will I
don't think he would I don't think he
would sometimes you got to go through
some [__] up [__] I'm just saying that
with that you saw many people defending
Mr B saying you know this is over five
years ago and arguing things like his
understanding and sensitivity about the
people featured and his content has
likely evolved okay so that's that's
just a bit oh no to me whether it's
somebody regaining their eyesight like
listen having good Footwear especially
you have to understand in large parts of
Africa there are no paved roads there's
a lot of trash in places glass on the
floor I remember like a lot of the walls
are actually just lined up with broken
glass you get what I'm trying to say
like there's a lot of hazardous stuff on
the floor so kids having access to good
Footwear can preserve their feet and you
need your feet especially in Africa
because [__] you gonna walk you're
gonna walk on some rough surfaces some
bad spots and you see a lot of people
get foot infections they end up having
to chop things off or they end up
getting hurt and they can't do the
things that they need to do so
I think it's a great initiative I think
these kinds of initiatives are very
admirable and I think considering the
landscape of content nowadays which is
very self-centered buying Bugattis
buying a bunch of other dumb [__] that's
completely frivolous and nonsensical you
can't do that it's okay these things are
not necessarily bad what I'm trying to
say is this is a nice counterbalance
it's nice to see this kind of stuff and
if people are doing good even if it is
for their own self-interest I don't care
because we need more good in the world
too many people are struggling
financially too many people are hurting
from a housing standpoint from a health
standpoint from an accessibility
standpoint to basic [__] Goods if
YouTubers want to use their hard-earned
money to create a system in which they
can help even if it's a thousand people
or a hundred people or 10 people I think
it's a beautiful thing so that's where I
stand on this of course anything else
you want to say you don't give a shout
out to Mr Beast Shout Out Mr Beast
it's just they're never happy they're
never happy they're never happy and you
can never you can never win the actual
thing that they asked yeah the actual
thing that they asked is happening not
happy not happy not happy I didn't like
the framing of him being a white man I
didn't like the framing of or why would
you film this because it helps the
business and he's able to help more
people and as long as everyone who's
involved can sense what's the issue it's
like none of you it's like you guys are
talking but none of you understand how
this [__] Works none of you but again I
only take people seriously who actually
engage in some form of help on their
local level to some degree if you don't
you need to shut the [__] up